al nuevo presidente de perú le esperan
varios retos pedro castillo ha hecho
promesas ambiciosas modificar la
constitución para cambiar la economía o
sacar al país de la pandemia pero sus
promesas son tan grandes como los
obstáculos que le esperan la economía
del país ha caído en picado en 2020 el
pib se desplomó en un 11% y la pandemia
ha agudizado la desigualdad en un país
donde casi el 60 por ciento de las
personas en las ciudades tienen trabajos
informales según el banco mundial la
pobreza no ha dejado de crecer desde
2016 y ya en 2019 afectaba al 20,2 por
ciento de la población en cuanto al
coronavirus perú es el país con la mayor
tasa de mortalidad por cada 100.000
habitantes en todo el mundo y la
vacunación avanza a un ritmo lento sin
embargo castillo ha prometido aumentar
la atención en cuidados intensivos
proveer más oxígeno y vacunar a todos
los mayores de 18 años antes de que
termine 2021 pero hay un reto más uno
que definirá todo su mandato se trata de
su libertad para gobernar en medio de
una fuerte oposición en él
el partido del castillo pero libre tiene
tan solo 37 de sus 130 escaños los
últimos gobiernos han enfrentado una
dura oposición principalmente del
fujimorismo y nada garantiza que su
mandato dure sólo en el último
quinquenio hubo cuatro presidentes
castillo ha llamado a la unión pero las
recientes elecciones mostraron una
fuerte división política con 18
candidatos a la presidencia en la
primera vuelta de la habilidad de
castillo para crear lazos políticos
dependerá no sólo su futuro en la
presidencia sino también que perú salga
de la crisis política y deje atrás la
pandemia